c'était un secret de polichinelle steven
guilbeault se lance dans la course à
l'investiture libérale de
laurier-sainte-marie farouchement contre
le rachat du pipeline trans manten
l'écologiste se dit malgré tout au
diapason avec le parti je me joins une
équipe qui souscrit l'ensemble de mes
principes que ce soit au niveau social
et environnemental
comme je l'aï dit je ne crois pas que le
fait que je sois en désaccord avec une
chose que le parti libéral a fait
annuler l'ensemble de ce qui était fait
par ce parti là par ce gouvernement long
cours des quatre dernières années
alors moi la seule chose que je peux
dire à stevens qui peut être faudrait
qu'ils arrêtent de chantier pour le
parti vert qui a courtisé l'écologiste à
plusieurs reprises la ligne de parti
sera trop forte pour défendre
véritablement les intérêts
environnementaux
il est clair que qu'il ya une
contradiction la plus totale
voici un écolo qui dit je suis content
le pipeline mais je suis pour justin
trudeau alors c'est un peu schizophrène
l'écologiste reconnu entre autres pour
ses coups d'éclat alors qu'il était à
greenpeace devra prouver qu'il est à la
hauteur
donc on espère que la présence de
monsieur guilbeault va mener davantage
d'ambitions la part des libéraux qui
pour l'instant ne livre pas la
marchandise d'un point de vue climatique
un doute que certains électeurs
partagent une ligne de parti c'est
toujours comme ça je l'arrêt plus vu
dans un autre parti politique je pense
lingots qui rassemblera que j'ai
l'impression qu'ils vont ramener pas mal
de gens
vis-à-vis lui steven guilbeault avoue
d'ailleurs qu'il aura besoin de
rassembler les canadiens autour des
enjeux climatiques
les militants qu'ils soient dans des
organisations environnementales qu'il
soit dans des entreprises qu'ils soient
dans des gouvernements on doit
travailler plus fort pour expliquer pour
sensibiliser la population canadienne
sur la question de la crise climatique
l'investiture se déroulera cet été mais
la partie est loin d'être gagnée
la circonscription n'a pas voté libéral
depuis plus de 20 ans ici marie josée
paquet comme radio canada montréal